have a look at this here's an ignition
question and this is definitely a
meeting you guys are asking for also a
TV a water person this is definitely
down the alley of what you're expecting
to see in the team in here I want you to
have a look and think we can go like
what's his first step that you could do
with an object like that that could be
helpful I can't all right put separating
the bigger numbers I the way that I
would wear that I like the idea of words
slightly differently I'm going to work
with the bases write the basis of the
issue here 6 + 3 + 8 I think we all
agree in all the bases were three is all
the base essentially you'd know exactly
what to do with this
you're like oh I just added to see I
just subtracting the sees what I'm
dividing and then I go right what causes
a problem you or what comes with
obstacle is that the bases aren't not
the same so I need to try and dig into
this a little bit and make the base of
the same so for example 6 right I can
break that up into pieces I can
factorize it 6 either by hands
cute anyway please write 2 times 3
there's six and it's been raised to the
power of 3x can I break this down be
better look I'll just leave that one
what about this guy
that's too cute there you go okay I
think it's the critical step so I've
broken down everything into prime
numbers I've chosen prime numbers
because once you have to find you can't
go any further and now this question is
just like what I was saying with almond
and similar faces so I can compare
things using your index laws you can see
if you've got two numbers in here and
boys being raised perhaps 3x because the
bracket so when I expand what will I
write that okay you've got a 3d X
hanging out over here and then down the
bottom here again because of index laws
these two County are going to be
multiplying it's just two to the preamp
okay fella it's all kids'll multiply
numbers at the same base so what you do
then you add happy